I want to demonstrate how to program
2006 2007 or maybe a few more Honda
Ridgeline
remote
buttons
okay because this has to be programmed
what they call it onboard programming
sorry I did not actually uh video when
they're actually doing it but basically
it's fairly simple now with this
particular model basically you have to
before entering
um
Remote programming mode you have to
cycle
I'll show you the step four times
instead of four times okay and until you
hear the uh the lock unlock cycle anyway
uh to be exact
basically uh just for demonstration
let's say this is the your original key
or program key
um meaning that you can start the car
similarly if you have another
program key you have to program this one
as well in terms of you know you cut the
key and then you program the key to
start so they both have to to start the
car okay that's the first step you have
to program
the key is so they start the car now
let's say this is original so what you
do to program the remote first step
you will
just know the thing this is the the lock
button okay you're gonna be pressing
this button you put the key into
ignition in the off position and then
you're gonna turn it on
a position which is the the two two
lines which is which is on but not all
the way to cranking the engine okay all
right let's start over you put the key
in
you turned it on to on position and then
you're gonna press the log key for like
one second
okay and then you're gonna turn to the
off position
turn it back on again within five
seconds press the lock button again
I'm gonna turn it off again I'm gonna
turn it on again you're gonna press the
lock button for like one second I'm
gonna turn it off again I'm gonna turn
it on
now once you press this you will hear
the door cycle meaning that it entering
Remote programming mode so on this key
you're gonna press the lock again for
one second and you should hear the lock
and unlock
and then on the additional key you can
go ahead and press the lock again
okay let's say you press it for like one
second you should hear the law cycle
again meaning that this remote has been
programmed you have another key you go
ahead and do the same thing just
hold on to that very simple
and then you should hear the the lock
cycle again and you
get the key out of your car and then
test all of your remote and that should
be it
so essentially for this particular car
instead of you do this press button you
do this press button to entering the
programming mode you have to do this for
Cycles if that makes sense
on other models I believe you only do
this two times
one press one press and then
I'll recycle and then you just press the
lock again blah blah blah if I can
remember but uh you know I was a little
confused at the beginning because based
on instruction
you only do this two times before
entering the programming mode anyway I
think in short you have any questions
let me know sorry I cannot do the actual
programming for you but uh also somebody
mentioned or someone if you have a on on
your key if you do have a tongue opening
you have to hold to test it you have to
hold the tongue opening for like 10
seconds
and then the trunk should open as well
okay so hope it helps and we see you
folks on the next video I will put the
instructions down below see you focus on
the next video bye for now